alors c'est ça que tu as pour cent
briques ça n'a pas été dur de te
retrouver toretto je me cachais pas
la semaine dernière une équipe de
pilotes parfaitement organisée a réussi
à s'emparer d'un convoi militaire
rio a été mon dernier job da je sais que
c'est pas toi
tu va m'aider à choper les coupables
ah ouais ok l'honneur obs on a traqué ce
gang à travers 12 pays
elles datent d'une semaine
c'est impossible j'ai besoin de toi at
home toi et ton équipe
il ya un bébé d'emploi termes là où
c'est toi qui va pleurnicher là les
meilleurs du monde réunis ici dans cette
pièce donne l'heure une bonne raison de
suivre ma possible owen choc un ancien
des forces spéciales
il ya des années qu'avec son dans qui
demandent des coûts en europe mais c'est
leur dernier exploit qui les a propulsés
sur la plus haute marche du podium
il ya déjà trop de cadavres derrière eux
je t'offre une chance de réunir sa
famille
une manne al hiti en cuivres chauds et
en échange d'une garantie l'immunité
totale sache peut pas que le promettre
c'est le deal à prendre ou à laisser
france ou crève
on n'a pas râlé flics ni à les
narcotrafiquants je n'ai encore jamais
vu ça
ces codes que vous respectez vous rendre
prévisible et dans la branche est
prévisible c'est l'une des rames
je peux vous trouvez vous massacrez
quand je veux
qui croit aux revenants
c'est peut-être plus là l'éthique on
connaissait on tourne pas le dos à la
famille même si elle l'a fait
lé ga
ils sont à touques
carrément
on est face à du véhicule de guerre
c'est pas notre calme